another major myth is that we and our
leaders only go to war for defensive
reasons and when forced by aggressors to
do so in this regard many view the
decision by president george w bush to
go to war against iraq in 2003 as an
anomaly a break from past american
history and traditions it is not the
fact that we went to war in iraq on the
basis of faulty or manipulated
intelligence regarding weapons of mass
destruction is also viewed incorrectly
as an anomaly in American history in
reality numerous past presidents have
presented incorrect information
sometimes knowingly sometimes
unknowingly in order to obtain
congressional and public approval of war
similarly incorrect is the belief that
we Americans always quote win the war
but lose the peace because of our
political naivete in point of fact the
reverse has often been the case the rest
of this lecture will attempt to dispel
such myths by examining presidential
behavior prior to America's major Wars
as well as the military history of those
Wars and the political results let's
look first at the issue of defensive
Wars vs. wars by choice historically
many if not most of our wars have been
Wars by choice in point in fact only
world will want to World War two were
Wars in which we were actually forced to
declare war by the previous actions of
our enemies in the nineteenth century
both the 1846 2:48 war with Mexico and
the 1898 war with Spain were Wars by
choice the first to acquire California
and New Mexico as well as a favorable
boundary for Texas and the second to
force the Spanish out of Cuba similarly
in the twentieth century we chose to go
to war in Korea and in Vietnam in the
1960s as part of the Cold War in a
somewhat gray
is the war of 1812 as President Madison
and the Congress went to war in
desperation because of the failure of
their previous measures of economic
coercion designed to force the British
to cease violating American neutral
rights on the high seas well what about
the Civil War the South chose to secede
and to fight for independence while the
North chose war in order to prevent this
similarly Americans chose to fight
against what they saw as British
violations of their rights in 1775 while
Britain chose to crush their rebellion
by force even in the two world wars our
enemies argued that our previous non
neutral acts had made us an unofficial
belligerent and forces them to attack us
in 1917 it was a booming trade in war
materiel and our loans to the Allied
powers that led the Germans to announce
unrestricted submarine warfare against
our shipping as well as everybody else's
in 1941 it was a freezing of Japanese
assets which in effect embargoed the oil
and steel that Japan relied upon and
that is what led Tokyo to try to obtain
these resources by force in Southeast
Asia and to attack the only military
force capable of stopping them the u.s.
fleet at Pearl Harbor
similarly the decision via the
lend-lease act of 1941 to give war
materiel free-of-charge first to Britain
and eventually to the Soviet Union and
then to use the US Navy to help convoy
that war materiel across the Atlantic
made the United States and unofficial
belligerent in the war against Germany
in all of these wars we argued that our
enemies left us no choice but to go to
war but because we made such a claim
does not mean that it was true